[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
always watch the blade I got it wow I'm
impressed you fight like your
grandfather
mom will practice it actually we just
finished like I told you always give you
iron the blade what's the point
I'm never gonna be good enough what's
wrong with you lately good thing you
know Emma
he's almost crumb he's about to leave
home isn't he I will go talk to him
why did this stop him I missed so much
hurry I don't want to this isn't an
ending ever more to come but you don't
know for sure what if I don't get a
second chance it's gonna be okay
just something to make things didn't
less terrify a little bottle rung
because I wouldn't say no it's a little
bottle of magic you speaki message and
here at the name of your favorite pirate
drop it in the water and before you can
say yellow hope I find the person you
seek
message in a barrel even thank you he's
grown into a fine young lad and he is
lucky to have a mother like you he's
lucky to have a pirate
he's gonna be fine
[Music]